and get my team is open by setting great
screens
wall into the basket finding guys and
you know China free trying to free them
up and then defensive it just you know
covering for for everybody you know
whenever I can't block a shot you know
do it just be all over the place you
know Joelle David kind of an ESPN back
here you told us in Toronto that you
wanted to kind of get back that joy get
back that effervescence that you bring
to the court when you had those two
blocks in the third quarter on Kauai and
then hit the shot and kind of backpedal
with a smile on your face did you feel
that stretch like that was you kind of
welcomed yourself back to the playoffs
getting over what you've been through um
many started from the gate from the
beginning company knowing that this was
you know do-or-die situation so I you
know I knew that I had to come in where
you know high spirits you know and you
know he played unusual like you always
does but that's that's what I got to
keep on doing you know do the low things
and everything is gonna follow over you
guys over here
rich Hoffman the athletic this is for
either of you guys after poor
performances it seems like you guys tend
to bounce back there were a few of those
in the regular season why do you guys
think that is then if you play back you
want to come back the next game and play
better you know we you know update until
all no we felt like you know we didn't
play the way we wanted to and we made a
lot of mistakes and tonight that had to
be corrected
especially with turnovers and you know
transition defense you know a bar was
aggressive then was was great tonight
Jimmy was great Tobias was great and
then defensive we call activity we did a
great job Joan Kennedy Liberty ballers
there is the one instance and second
half you were reinserted in the game
after only a minute on the bench have
you been given any guidance about how
much you're you know willing to be
pushed out there like how far you can go
especially with the game come up
oh man that shouldn't tell me then they
haven't told me stuff layups
I got a play if I gotta play 45 minutes
and push myself harder that's what I
gotta do if that's what it takes to win
that if my presence on the court you
know he's needed I gotta be there
doesn't doesn't matter if he takes the
whole game so and I'm fine with it not
to keep on pushing myself at you know a
game seven we're gonna need it I'm gonna
need to be on the court you know and I
intend to be ready for if for everything
if I had to play a whole game Jimmy
Jimmy a back road to your left here
number times they made runs at you and
you guys he heard a counterpunch back
just talk about the religion scene I
showed that I let's see that fourth
quarter where they get to that eight
then you guys just kind of went to a
gerund to control it just to go from
that point I think the the game is a
game of runs as a whole it's all about
withstanding those runs and more than
anything I just think tonight we let our
defense start us out and dictate our
offense which would I always say
whenever we play like that we're hard to
beat home on a roll neutral site that's
how we have to play basketball
how do you feel right now and how do you
feel how did you feel going into this
game compared to the other games earlier
in the series I'm good
the other games audio necessaries I was
great I'm great today
Joella on your way off the floor in
Toronto you laid it may be known you'd
be coming back onto your left she left
I'd let it be know that you'll be coming
back for Game seven now that this
moment's here what emotions going into a
do-or-die situation and Game seven Scott
Lee basketball you know basketball is
fun understand you know that I
understand that is Game seven you know
gotta come in and you know fight just
like we did tonight
you know our back was on the line
tonight I feel like our back is still on
the line he's on the line so we just
gotta do the same thing and come back
and like you say it's all about the
offense man if we play defense I would
play tonight in game 2 1 & 3 then we
feel like we can beat anybody so we got
to come in and be ready
JoEllen Jenny on your right what did
Jimmy mean to you guys in the first half
and did you feel like you had to come
out and sort of take things over in the
first half of it it seemed like you
played that one I just came out
aggressive as they tell me to be all the
time game simple I shoot the ball and
I'm open sometimes I shoot it when I'm
not open and you know I try to get out
in transition get some steals get some
rebounds and take off that's that's just
how the game went for us and I home
crowd crowd was great no booze
ah they put a little bit right baby okay
they blew this a bit we appreciate it
but all in all there's really
I was great carried us offensively and
defensively obviously you know for the
last day that he had before the half was
huge
especially for